>> Education is vital in preventing disease
and poverty and improving
standards of living.
Governments typically don't invest enough
in this and there need to be
more substantial and sustained commitments
to the funding and financing
of education, the reform of education services
globally.
This is a matter of [INAUDIBLE] who and its
very important that
business works with government to identify
education that is going to
help to increase jobs.
It's not about education systems and schools,
it's also about
investment and the kind of education that
is provided and this has to
be relevant to the needs of employers but
also the needs of communities
and people in communities.
And this challenge is vital now to meet the
growing needs of young
people coming into the workforce.
Finally, education is vital to prepare for
a different future, for a
low carbon-type economy, for radically different
ways of consuming and
the levels of consumption.
So education and investment in education is
vital now.